you got one of four choices which one do
you want to be you can be the richest
man in America Bill Gates you can be the
best athlete on America Michael Jordan
you can be the best performer in the
world Michael Jackson or you can be the
president who do you want to be and we
debated for 30 minutes so it's great at
that time it would probably be money
because I grew poor if I could jump 48
inches that listen are you kidding me I
mean it's not even a question about it
same answer right now you'd be the
athlete if you could jump 48 inches it's
not just that yeah you're gonna get the
billion because you're Michael Jordan
how would you ever want to be Bill Gates
most of those answers sounded
unappealing Michael Jackson God nobody
wants to be that Bill Gates Jesus